even christmas isn't safe from the
coronavirus pandemic the cdc recommends
that people celebrate virtually this
year or only with members
of their own household professor laurie
santos created the most popular class
in yale university's history it is
called psychology and the good life
she also hosts the happiness lab podcast
and she joins us now with ideas to make
the most of our virtual
gatherings professor good morning good
to see you
thanks so much for having me on the show
so you've said happy people take time
for social connection
how can we do that now given our current
situation
well i think most of our social
connection except those within our
family have to take place virtually
which isn't great i mean it's worth
acknowledging that this you know sucks
this wasn't the holiday season we
planned
but the cool thing is that we we have
lots of tools that we can use to connect
with one another
right you know zoom happy hour is like
you know face time new year's
celebrations like you know netflix
parties these are all ways that we can
connect with one another
and try to be social even though we're
not physically together
you know i have a very close-knit family
lori and it's been really hard because
everyone lives in different places we've
got canada minnesota washington state
california the virtual happy hour got a
little old
so this week we ended up doing a
scavenger hunt
i was skeptical at first it turned into
one of the most fun things so as long as
you get creative with some of this stuff
i think it really can bring a lot of joy
to people
yeah i think this is one of the things
we forget you know we get used to doing
zoom calls at work you know at work it's
very formal you know you're sitting
there you know facing each other and
stuff
but that's not how family and friend
activities work right you need to make
it a little less formal right you need
to get a little bit creative
and sometimes that means treating your
zoom call a little bit different than
you would at work you know
these days when i'm zooming with family
members over dinner like i get up you
know if i'm gonna like make a drink i'd
bring the cocktail stuff and you know
get it set up right there right
try to bring in the sort of interactions
that you would normally have over zoom
that you normally have in real life over
zoom and then you can make that social
event much more fun
professor santos eureka duncan here i
want to switch gears a little bit i know
that you talk about your class being one
of the toughest ones when you talk about
practicing happiness
and saying it's not about being aware
but it's also about actually doing the
things
day in and day out to make sure you stay
less stressed and happy
what number one tip would you give our
viewers and to us
to remain happy what should we be
practicing
well the easiest one is to take control
over something that we can all take
control over which is just
our breath you know we talk about taking
a deep breath when you're anxious but
the research shows that that activates
your sympathetic nervous system like it
really can allow you to shut off your
fight or flight system
and sort of turn on that rest and digest
system which we all need
another thing you can do is to take time
for gratitude right in tough times we
don't often think about counting our
blessings
but research shows that the simple act
of listing things you're grateful for
can really boost your mood
finally another thing you can do is to
sort of take time to think about other
people you know when we're in
challenging times we can get stuck on
thinking about ourselves self-care treat
yourself but as you talked about earlier
in the show you know the act of doing
kind things for others doing things
outside of yourself becoming other
oriented that's a real boost for
happiness
and then you know the last thing i
always suggest is that when times are
tough
it's worth admitting that times are
tough don't pretend that there's not
going to be
sadness and anger and anxiety over this
holiday season really take time to
notice and feel those emotions
that's part of happiness science too and
jamie mentioned having a zoom scavenger
hunt professor
what other zoom activities for those of
us who are a little zoom fatigued
would you offer up
yeah well i think again it involves
getting creative one thing is to try to
do
an activity together this year there's
no spoilers to my family who's watching
right now but i'm mailing out little
gingerbread kits
and so each of us you know in our own
town is going to be doing our own
gingerbread kit and we can kind of
decide who did it better
things like netflix parties even games
you know like that you can play over
zoom
these are just fun ways to kind of get
to know each other a little bit better
and to make the best use of our time a
final way to get creative is really to
bring in people you wouldn't normally
bring in
right you know our dinner table live is
kind of constrained right you can't
bring people
from all over the world from different
time zones but you know bring a friend
from high school that your family hasn't
seen in a long time
yeah thank you so much professor santos
we appreciate it